[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oir
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore on tout le monde
là souff léger on pas les sur le
[Applaudissements]
ma
ça
[Applaudissements]
ok
ok mais tu sais la Chine d'aujourd'hui
c'est ça c'est ce qu'on voit he qu tu
veux inventer d'autre he tu vas pas la
cine des petits temples et
tout on en a
fait dans la route là ça ça un plan pour
nous ça tu vois
hein pour ça ça du coup
[Musique]
de la Chine un des plus gros exportateur
de maïs du monde et c'est la première
fois que j'exporte
pas parce que y a une crise cette année
de de G dans le monde
[Musique]
entier pas pourquoi vas-y
voilà tu vas tu vas voilà c'est assez
marrant il pied d'argent enc ça partout
partout partout je pense que ça gne de
la de la chaleur je pense ça gne de la
chaleur pas bar
ça en dessous en dessous vertic en
vertical
pratiquement très
verticale qui est marrant mon
avis ah c'est des pommes c'est des
pommes il y a des pommes dessus si tu
zoomes dessus tu verras les pommes voilà
soit bien vertical j'essaie de
[Applaudissements]
revenir ch
doucement sol sol
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
St pas qu'il a eu trop bas aussi
hein sortir du truc attends
Onas beaucoup plus de contre pas c'est
pas Danson c'est
[Applaudissements]
pas voilà voilà joli que sur
leses dans le sens du soleil très contre
jour c'est très très
beau prendre chemins
de pas
paséli regarde regarde voilà c'est là
VO va le
[Musique]
REF
lar
onour
gauche à
gauche
pas dans les sens
moach
[Musique]
sur
[Applaudissements]
traver voilà voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voil plusantoup plus
br
[Applaudissements]
à mon avis tu trop devant
pas la maison voilà c'est devant la
maison ente que c'est joli
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà oh
merde il faut que tu te
[Applaudissements]
ok de pour voir o tuprès tu
prendon
venir
ilutour
tu vois pas c'est terrible ça
pouri pas le
truc ça c'est un truc qu'it pas en
France c'est
marrant
par ramener de la lumière ha auuit à mon
avis
aussi en bas oui allez on va tourner à
gauche
[Applaudissements]
VO en a
beaucoup de la maison
ok à droite de la
maison voil des f électrique c'est chier
ça
OK
qui sont là c'est pour pas je comprends
pas aller F dev nous
c'est passessus vasy regarde
bien regarde
bien devant nous voilà partie BR
devantasy voilà voilà voilà
voilz
vas-y dans ton point et c'est parti
un petit peu quand
même ça plus en
de écarte-toi
écartetoicarte-toi en all dessous en all
dessous ouis avant
il faut que tu tournes
oh n arrive pas ce truc fait
chier ça oh merde merde
merde
[Applaudissements]
OK dans tous les
sensir en dessous de moi
[Musique]
voilà
voilà ça pas
monte un petit peu monte un petit peu
devant monte un peu devant monte voilà
voilà voilà monte monte monte
[Applaudissements]
voilà travers je sais pas où tu es là
pas tu es pas du tout devant es sur le
côté mon pote tu pas devant sur le
côté tu nes pas devant du
toutter tu pas devant
voilà
voil camé plus
[Musique]
devant
ça voil là es enin d tourne tourne tour
tour voilà c'est
unu voilà voilà
parfait
voilà comme c'est beau c'est bon ça
[Applaudissements]
je v avis tu
es
tu ve faire quelque chose faire
[Applaudissements]
pas c'est vachement beau
ça V
d
[Applaudissements]
pasble aprè si tu veux qu'on fasse du
détail il faut qu'on remette dessus
[Applaudissements]
station est
d
[Musique]
est va BR plus en
dessous
[Applaudissements]
vachement devant là super
[Musique]
ça
pas sur un des trucs
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
là
c'est
bon
OKC parce qu'onte